grounded airplanes a potential nightmare
for the British airline fly be in Exeter
come March 2019 about 30% of the
carrier's flights are either to or from
the EU but leaving Europe's aviation
market could strip fly be like all
British Airlines of their operating
licenses for the EU if it were a cliff
edge extreme what I call copy umbilical
cord those 30% do it exist any longer
that would be my interpretation of an
extreme hard brexit they don't exist
those flights would not continue to
operate but that has not yet stopped fly
B from selling tickets for flights after
brexit if you stopped sales and your
competitors remain in place then you're
handing it to them and who knows the
outcome of brexit so we continue to
remain on sale we continue to sell seats
air traffic rights are just one post
brexit problem another prickly issue is
airplane safety currently only the e use
aviation safety agency can give planes
approval to fly the UK government wants
to stay a full member of the institution
but the EU says Paul Everett has ruled
out cherry-picking agreements
unfortunately on both sides of the
negotiations it is effectively a
political negotiation both in the UK and
in Europe so this you know and those
political priorities are at the moment
kind of shaping what can and can't
happen but if change is necessary
we are already you know not so much five
minutes to midnight we're in you know a
minute to midnight Territory the
interests are vast the UK aerospace
industry generates 36 billion euros in
revenues a year and employ some 120,000
people London City Airport CEO Robert
Sinclair tells us that it was Europe's
liberalized aviation market that drove
down prices and made flying affordable
for all our markets and our countries in
our economies and the free flow of
passengers for many many years is so
interrelated so in two
connected and it's actually in the
interests of all sides in the UK but
also in mainland Europe to maintain that
level of connectedness that that people
have enjoyed for so many years Sinclair
would like to see the aviation market
separated from the more contentious
issues in the brexit negotiations but
the other 27 EU countries remain closely
aligned unwilling to give away the --use
most obvious advantages up front the
UK's aviation industry expected some
turbulence but now a storm is coming the
industry feels they've become a
bargaining chip in the negotiations and
that makes the prospect that plain good
stay grounded a lot more real